The two color yarn changer requires three
parts the front bed extension,
the two color changer,
also called a feed box and the curved
cam inserted in the back bed
main rail.
The first thing to recognize is
that the fasteners that attach
the extension plate are in two parts.
There's a threaded post
and a threaded nut.
If you remove the nut, sometimes
the threaded post will also be removed.
Use a screwdriver to separate them. First
install the front bed extension
with the threaded post and nut.
If you already had a four color changer
installed, remove the three part curved
cam and replace it with the single
bed curved cam underneath the bed.
Removed the threaded post
and threaded nuts from the back bed.
Slip the color changer over the posts
that are in place in the bed
and secure them with the wing nut.
With this color changer,
you'll be able to quickly change colors
without having to rethread
your machine each time.